Here are the four answers. Great work if you found those. We know what pattern
of I repeats every fourth power, so we want to take this power of 21 and divide
it by 4. Doing so we get 5 remainder 1. This means I to the 21st power is
equivalent to I to the 21, which we know is really just I. For the second one
we'll take the power of 11 and divide it by 4... Which is 2 remainder 3. So we
know i to the 11th, is equivalent to i to the 3rd, which equals -i. Since i to
the 48th is a multiple of 4, we end up on a power of i to the 4th, which is
really just 1. When thinking about it with a remainder, we know 48 divided by 4
equals 12 remainder 0. i to the 48th is equal to i to the 0, which equals 1.
And finally for i to the 66th, we divide the power by 4 to get 16 remainder 2.
This means that we cycle through the patterns of i 16 times and then wind up
with i squared, which is equal to negative 1. If this is still giving you
trouble try repeating these values all the way up to i to the 11th. You'll
start seeing the pattern repeat and hopefully you'll catch the hang of it.